From undersea battles to crime-solving Pokemon,
November was filled with exciting glimpses
of upcoming movies.
Here are all the November trailers that showcased
some of the best looking new films.
Will the merc with a filthy mouth still bring
enough of his trademark charm in a PG-13 film?
That's the experiment 20th Century Fox is
running this December by releasing a cleaned
up version of Deadpool 2 for Christmas.
That should work.
"The first order of business is to get me
in front of Cable so I can pull all the f------
blood out of his body and fashion his bones
into holiday jewelry."
Although to be honest, since you can't tell
what Ryan Reynolds' mouth is doing under that
mask, it can't be too hard to dub in some
more family-friendly jokes.
Just look at all the versions of this scene:
"ooh, yeah, your bullets.
They're really fast."
"Those bullets are like super fast."
“Ow.”
Once Upon a Deadpool will also apparently
feature some entirely new scenes featuring
Fred Savage back in his role as the little
kid in bed from The Princess Bride.
Check it out when Once Upon a Deadpool hits
theaters on December 12th.
As the director of The Lord of the Rings,
Peter Jackson is a guy who knows a thing or
two about big, epic films, and few stories
fit that description better than Mortal Engines.
Although he won't be directing, Jackson is
producing and co-writing this dystopian story
about massive rolling cities that eat other
cities.
Because, really, what else would a giant city
eat?
Tuna fish sandwiches?
While we've had plenty of glimpses of Mortal
Engines in the past months, November saw an
extended trailer that focuses more on the
crazy world of the film.
Take a look when Mortal Engines premieres
on December 14th.
After becoming the surprise star of Justice
League in 2017, Jason Momoa is back in the
role of Aquaman in a standalone movie that'll
see him fighting to save Atlantis from his
half-brother Orm and taking on a swarm of
deep-sea monsters called the Trench.
Oh, and Black Manta is in there, too.
It's clear that Warner Bros. has a lot of
faith in this movie, and all signs point to
an outrageously fun big-screen adventure for
DC fans.
After all the jokes at his expense
"Let’s go buddy!”
“I’m coming!”
“Hahaha”
“Last one to the party can't fly."
maybe Aquaman will finally get the last laugh.
You can take the dive when Aquaman arrives
on December 21st.
Keanu Reeves headlines this sci-fi thriller
as a scientist who finds himself in dire straits
after he clones his dead family.
"How could you do this?”
“… Because I love you."
Apparently, he broke some rules when he fired
up his big ol' clone oven, because now the
government's gunning for him and his family.
What's a simple scientist to do?
Fight back to save his loved ones - again.
Replicas has been a long time coming - it
was announced in 2014 and began production
in 2016, marking a nearly five year journey
to the big screen.
Hopefully, it was worth the wait.
Replicas hits theaters on January 11th, 2019.
M. Night Shyamalan's Glass is building a lot
of hype, and November's minute-long TV spot
highlights Kevin Crumb's "Beast" persona and
more scenes from some kind of battle against
the police.
Of course, being an M. Night Shyamalan film,
there's no doubt that Glass is going to feature
plenty of twists that aren't being touched
on in the trailers.
Tellingly, none of the trailers show what
Mr. Glass is up to outside of that psychiatric
hospital.
That's all the more reason to check it out
when Glass breaks into theaters on January
18th.
Serenity has equal potential to be either
a harrowing, mind-bending thriller or a whole
bunch of crap.
It's hard to tell at this point!
Matthew McConaughey stars as the captain of
a fishing boat enjoying the quiet island life
in the tropics.
He's reunited with his Interstellar costar
Anne Hathaway, who asks him to kill her husband.
From that launching point, the trailer dives
into a world of paranoia and backstabbing,
with hints that there's a bigger plotline
at work behind the scenes.
"This whole island's a part of it, but nobody
knows it."
Serenity was written and directed by Steven
Knight, who previously put out 2013's Locke,
starring Tom Hardy, and wrote the screenplay
for David Cronenberg's Eastern Promises.
Look for Serenity to drop into theaters on
January 25th, 2019.
Right now, there are two camps when it comes
to Alita: Battle Angel.
On one side, people seem to be having a little
trouble dealing with the decision to make
Alita's eyes big and anime-like.
"So what do you say?
“I say no.
It's not art."
On the other side, you have people who are
genuinely excited to see the beloved manga
come to the big screen.
Ultimately, it'll come down to how well the
film handles the story.
Sure, some of the CGI looks a little goofy,
and Alita's relationship with the boy in the
trailers smells a lot like high school melodrama.
"You are the most human person I have ever
met,"
Fingers crossed that none of that will drag
the film down.
With both Robert Rodriguez and James Cameron
working behind the scenes to bring Alita to
life, there's still a chance this could be
one of the surprise hits of 2019.
Find out when it lands on February 14th.
The future just got a whole lot more interesting
with the release of the second teaser for
Captive State.
Like the first teaser, this one showcases
a world in turmoil as humanity tries to win
back its freedom from a ruling class of extraterrestrials.
Rise of the Planet of the Apes director Rupert
Wyatt is helming and co-writing the film,
with Ashton Sanders and John Goodman starring.
Check it out in March 2019.
Ryan Reynolds is set to star in Detective
Pikachu, providing the weirdly deep voice
of Pokemon's iconic yellow electric mouse-thing.
"I know you can't understand me but put down the stapler or
I will electrocute you."
The story sees Pikachu teaming up with a young
man named Tim Goodman to find Goodman's father,
a detective who went missing.
Since Goodman is apparently the only human
who can understand what Pikachu is actually
saying, they have to work together to navigate
the magical world of adorable Pokemon critters
to solve the case.
You gotta catch Detective Pikachu in theaters
on May 10th, 2019.
It's been eight years since Toy Story 3 left
Buzz, Woody, and everyone else in the care
of little Bonnie while Andy left for college.
It was an ending that was both heartbreaking
and heartwarming, and it made the perfect
close to the relationship between Andy and
the lovable gang of toys.
Until now.
Disney/Pixar is bringing them back into our
lives in 2019 with Toy Story 4, which will
follow the toys on a new adventure that hopefully
will be just as touching as the preceding
three films.
The main voice cast is returning, with Tom
Hanks and Tim Allen voicing Woody and Buzz,
respectively.
Hanks has remarked that the ending of Toy
Story 4 is particularly emotional.
Get ready to weep openly in a movie theater
in June 2019.
After months of anticipation, Disney finally
released the first trailer for their upcoming
live-action remake of The Lion King - and
it kind of looks exactly like the original
film.
The teaser mostly focuses on the opening scene
from the 1994 version, showing baby Simba
on Pride Rock as Rafiki anoints his head with
red baboon juice - or in this case, dust.
Another shot the trailer shows is a sweeping
view of a herd of wildebeests stampeding into
a gorge while Mufasa's voice says, "The sun
will set on my time here."
That's clearly some not-so-subtle foreshadowing
that the 2019 movie will probably recreate
the scene that made our six-year-old selves
realize that life was a meaningless void.
“ahh”
Anyway!
That new Simba sure does look cute!
We just can't wait for The Lion King to hit
theaters in July 2019.